let's talk about the seven ways that you can boost
your testosterone these are natural things you can
do the first thing is to make sure you do not
lower your cholesterol you want to increase
your cholesterol do not go on a low fat diet why
because cholesterol is the precursor the building
blocks that help make testosterone and that's
one of the problems too when your doc puts you
on statins statins block cholesterol which then
end up lowering testosterone and that is one big
challenge so i'm not telling you not to take
your statin all i'm saying is that you might
want to research it get with your doctor and find
out the real reason why your cholesterol might be
high and i have some videos on that instead of
just treating the symptom let's find out what
the actual cause is but you don't want to go low
on the cholesterol if you want high testosterone
let's talk about protein moderate protein a myth
is that you need a lot of protein to stimulate
your testosterone no you need a moderate amount
now what's a moderate amount well i'd say about
between six to eight ounces per meal now i'm
talking about the weight of the actual food
like a piece of steak or a hamburger or something
like that i'm not talking about the grams within
that because the grams within that is a lot less
i do have quite a few videos on protein i'll put
some down below if you want more information on
that but you just want to avoid too much protein
if you consume too much protein you're
going to get tired and the reason why
you're going to get tired is that your like
half of it can easily be turned into glucose
so when you turn it into glucose because
your body doesn't necessarily use amino acids
as its fuel some but not much it has to
be converted into glucose to be used as
fuel so that excess amount of insulin that's
triggered by the glucose is going to block
your testosterone so just do a moderate amount of
protein number three you want to go low carbs for
the same reason because carbs increase insulin
so if we keep our insulin low we can enhance
testosterone and other beneficial hormones like
growth hormone number four exercise will stimulate
testosterone if it's high intensity and oval
training or exercise involving the whole body
to the point where you're sweating but not over
training but the problem is if you're not sleeping
you don't want to do that okay because it's
going to strain your heart you want to do long
walks for a while to lower the cortisol so you can
sleep so you can eventually add more exercise to
then increase more testosterone now just as a side
note and i didn't put this on this chart is that i
always recommend when you do low carb it's called
keto you also do intermittent fasting intermittent
fasting improves growth hormone and wherever
growth hormone goes testosterone goes it tends
to follow similar pathways and so intermittent
fasting is vital to keep your testosterone levels
normal because if you're doing snacks and frequent
meals you're just going to increase insulin and
suppress testosterone that is why a pre-diabetic
or someone with insulin resistance or a diabetic
normally always has low testosterone and that's
going to affect your muscle mass and it's going
to affect your libido and your energy number five
sleep very very important why because we want to
keep our cortisol lower increase cortisol
the stress hormone we lower testosterone we
also want to keep estrogen on the low side so you
want to avoid soy products especially soy protein
isolates which is in a lot of diet foods and like
the fake meat and things like that and then you
want to avoid things that increase estrogen
so you want to do organic because pesticides
insecticides act like estrogen in the body they're
called estrogen mimickers or endocrine disruptors
there are certain supplements that can also
help you as well the most important one is zinc
about 100 milligrams per day this will actually
work very well another good one that i recommend
is the korean red ginseng this not only improves
testosterone but it's going to improve your energy
it's going to give you a sense of calmness it'll
give you stamina it'll give you vitality it's a
really really good herb it's been used for a very
long long time with great success l-arginine will
increase something called nitric oxide which
can increase testosterone it's a good supplement
but remember any time you're doing supplements
they may not work if your diet isn't corrected
and if you don't know what to eat i put a link
down below and then we have something called d
aspartic acid another really good compound to
help increase testosterone last few points if
you have a fatty liver and you're looking down you
have a gut you have a fatty liver that's going to
inhibit your ability to make testosterone so you
want to work on removing the fat from your liver
by doing a moderate protein low-carb ketogenic
diet also if your iron is too high that can
suppress your testosterone and it can destroy your
liver so i always recommend if you're male not to
take iron supplements and even post-menopausal
women who are no longer menstruating should be
careful too because iron in excess is very harmful
to your liver and hormones and it's very difficult
for your body to get rid of iron so you want to
be careful not to get it in supplements which
you might even not be aware of when you read the
label it's like wow i've been taking all this iron
no i wouldn't recommend that and statins i already
talked about that point all right there you go
seven ways to boost your testosterone hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled how
to bulletproof your immune system it's a free
course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today